he's an aerospace engineer noted for
designing light strong unusual-looking
energy-efficient aircrafts he designed
the record-breaking Voyager which was
the first plane to fly around the world
without stopping or refueling he
designed the first privately funded
spacecraft to enter space twice within a
two-week period
he's burt rutan and here are his top 10
rules for success someone asked him
what's the most difficult thing about
going to the moon and he says the will
to do it the engineering is just
calculations but the decision and the
will in the courage to try to do it is
the most difficult hurdle we are known
for trying new things even though we
have a tough schedule we did an airplane
that we that the customer wanted it
flying within I think is eight and a
half months and we elected on our own to
try a totally new manufacturing method
for the wings and tail surfaces and
control surfaces something that hadn't
been done before something that may not
work something that was really exciting
and interesting and if it did work it
its breakthrough stuff our first
astronaut Alan Shepard who flew us
suborbital flight followed Gagarin by
only three weeks after Shepards flight
it took only seven-and-a-half years for
us to launch Apollo eight to go out and
orbit the moon they went to the moon on
the very first manned flight of the big
Saturn 5 now can you imagine today NASA
developing a brand new huge big advanced
rocket and the first time people fly on
it they go to the moon or they go
somewhere we've never been before that
puts in perspective the kind of risks
that we that we were taking and those
who put themselves in a position to take
enormous risks are those that have
breakthroughs and those that that have
research results I believe that
confidence in nonsense is a major factor
and the reason is think of the most
important breakthrough that you can
think of go back before it was
recognized as a breakthrough and the
populace normally would consider well
that's nonsense
that's nonsensical and all of a sudden
when it really is recognized as a true
breakthrough then of course oh yeah
that's really cool but what people
forget is it's nonsense before well what
that means that's why the weird folk
have the breakthroughs because they have
confidence in nonsense if it's
nonsensical and you say well I'm not
gonna try to do that it didn't make
sense you're not gonna have a
breakthrough the guy who is silly enough
to think that hey I'll try that even
though it's nonsense he's the guy that's
gonna have the breakthrough so try
things that you don't think will work if
you think they'll work you're not doing
research anyway you're gonna have
failures if you try hard stuff if you go
out and try to build a better sea plane
and your goal is to go 12 knots faster
well you're probably not going to fail
you may fail because it only goes 4
knots faster but it's not going to be a
disaster failure but if you go out and
try something that that is holy crap can
you really do that and it fails it is a
failure and I feel very strongly that
it's not good enough
for us to have generations of kids that
think that it's ok to look forward to a
better version of a cell phone with a
video in it they need to look forward to
exploration they need to look forward to
colonization they need to look forward
to breakthroughs they need to we need to
inspire them because they need to lead
us and help us survive in the future
what I try to encourage people to do is
to have a breakthrough by finding a way
to do it more simply and even if the
real simple one
it has a chance of not working because
it's too simple we'll try it anyway
because in trying it sometimes you'll
stumble on to a solution on why it
wouldn't work and now you've really had
a big gain now you have a simple thing
that does work and that's that's the
real the real challenge now you can
always make something work by adding
complexity but you can never make
something affordable by adding
complexity
I think breakthroughs occur not when
everybody's doing fine and when you're
when your priority is to make everyone
equally happy you don't have
breakthroughs then that's monotony and
that can lead to monotony in it and it
can lead even to your ability to survive
but you have breakthroughs either during
or after crises when you have really bad
times we're creative when we're
threatened I think the world of aviation
will gain from me mostly inspiration the
fact that a few people literally in a
garage or a small shop built an airplane
that doubled an absolute distance record
flew all the way around the world flew
through all this weather and came back
home safely the fact that that was done
all-composite
without mixing metals without solving
all these stupid problems that the
engineers made for themselves that will
provide the inspiration
my god it can be done we're gonna do it
we'll stick our necks out I knew how the
Wright brothers felt when they came upon
these things and and had success this is
the best way this was one thing and that
was a passion that I saw in your eyes
for the outcome and I knew you would
stick with it because I knew that
passion with Jenny when you go out of
venture capital into whatever you're
looking for people who have a passion
for money but you have a passion for
space life and I think that's the
difference
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jeremiah Omata
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur do you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Burt Rutan's top 10 rules
for success you loved the most
leave it in the comments and I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon